Alkenes are useful synthetic intermediates;
their double bonds can undergo a variety of
chemical transformations, providing useful
functional groups like halides, alcohols,
and carbonyl compounds.
Let’s review some of the major reactions
that alkenes undergo.
An alkene can be reacted with hydrogen gas
in the presence of a metal catalyst to produce
alkanes.
The hydrogen gas adds to one face of the alkene,
so we get syn addition of H2 across the double
bond.
Alkenes react with halogen-containing acids,
like hydrochloric and hydrobromic acid, adding
a single halogen across the double bond.
If the alkene is reacted with acid in the
presence of water or an alcohol, the result
is an alcohol or an ether.
Water or the alcohol can be used as solvent
in this reaction.
You may have noticed these reactions are regioselective;
in our example, the new functional group is
added to the central carbon, and not the terminal
carbon of the alkene.
This is because these reactions form a carbocation
intermediate.
The more substituted carbocation forms because
it is more stable.
Because carbocations are trigonal planar in
geometry, they can be attacked by the nucleophile
from the top face or the bottom face, so if
there is a stereocenter produced in the reaction,
it will be a mixture of R and S. When this
happens, we say a “racemic mixture” is
produced.
The addition of the nucleophile to the more
substituted carbon of the alkene is sometimes
referred to as Markovnikov addition and is
related to carbocation stability.
Rearrangements via hydride or alkyl shift
are possible with these acid-promoted reactions.
Treatment of an alkene with liquid bromine
or chlorine gas adds two atoms of the halogen
across the double bond, and if the reaction
is carried out in water, a halohydrin is formed.
The latter reaction is again regioselective
and stereoselective.
A bromonium ion forms, and the nucleophile
attacks at the more substituted carbon atom,
because there is significant contribution
of the more stable carbocation resonance form
here.
This accounts for the regioselectivity.
The functional groups are also added to the
molecule stereoselectively.
Because the bromonium ion blocks one face
of the molecule, the nucleophile must approach
from the opposite side.
We call this anti addition.
Allylic bromination is a radical reaction
that adds a bromine atom to the carbon adjacent
to the double bond, while preserving the alkene
functional group.
Oxymercuration also forms alcohols from alkenes
in a Markovnikov fashion.
A mercurinium ion is formed, which reacts
with water at the more substituted carbon
atom.
Treatment with sodium borohydride reduces
the mercury, removing it from the molecule.
The major advantage of this reaction is that
carbocation rearrangements by hydride or alkyl
shift are not possible, although mercury is
a rather toxic element to use in the lab.
Hydroboration/oxidation forms the less substituted
alcohol via non-Markovnikov addition.
Boron is often substituted with large R groups
to make this reaction more selective; examples
of commonly used reagents are 9-BBN, disiamyl
borane, and borane-THF.
The large boron group adds to the least sterically
hindered side of the alkene, while the small
hydride atom is added to the more substituted
carbon atom.
Treatment of the boron complex with sodium
hydroxide and peroxide in a second stage of
the reaction produces the alcohol.
The addition of two hydroxyl groups across
the alkene is accomplished by treatment with
osmium tetraoxide, which forms an osmate ester.
This reaction gives a syn diol because osmium
approaches from one face.
One molar equivalent of a reducing agent is
required to cleave osmium from the molecule
and produce the diol.
Ozonolysis essentially splits a double bond
in half, creating a carbonyl compound from
each side.
In our example, a substituted aldehyde and
formaldehyde are formed.
We need to take a look at the mechanism to
understand what is going on here.
The addition of ozone forms a molozonide,
which rearranges to form the ozonide.
In a second step, dimethyl sulfate is added.
This cleaves the oxygen-oxygen bond, and the
charged intermediate collapses to form carbonyl
compounds and dimethylsulfoxide.
The Wittig reaction is an alkene forming reaction
that seems relevant to touch on here.
A carbonyl compound is converted into an alkene
by treatment with an organophosphorous reagent.
This “Wittig reagent” is a phosphorous
ylide; although we can draw a resonance structure
with a double bond, there is also contribution
from a neutral dipolar form.
The carbanion form makes it a bit more apparent
how the carbon atom of the Wittig reagent
ends up bonded to the electrophilic carbonyl
carbon of an aldehyde or ketone.
The side product of this reaction is triphenylphosphene
oxide.
Z-Alkenes are favored under classical Wittig
conditions; when there is a possibility for
resonance stabilization of the carbanion,
the E-alkene is more favored.
Alkene metathesis, though a bit more advanced,
is an important reaction in modern synthesis.
Treatment of two alkenes with molybdenum or
ruthenium catalysts results in the formation
of a new alkene with substitution from the
original alkenes on either side of the double
bond.
This reaction is most useful when it done
in an intramolecular fashion to close a ring.